the results are in Bola ahmatinebu has
been declared the winner of Nigeria's
presidential race
[Music]
but opposition parties are contesting
the outcome
president-elect tinubu is known as a
political King maker and is one of the
most influential people in the country
he was expected to win by those who
thought he'd call in favors with the
governors who's helped elect Across the
Nation but the youth have galvanized a
platform of 61 year olds labor party
Peter Obi who beat tinubu in his
backyard in Lagos State
[Music]
opposition parties have called this
election a sham and today in the wake of
the announcement the people's Democratic
party the main opposition party have
mobilized people here in protest asking
for the election results to be nullified
voter disenfranchisement and incidences
of violent appalling stations across the
country as well as the failure of the
Electoral commission to digitally upload
results have left many people here
feeling like the electoral process was
not successful
[Music]
has cited his experience as a private
businessman an accountant and a former
Governor as an indication of his
capacity to lead the country out of
economic ruins his campaign is one of
renewed hope that the young people we've
met has said that he doesn't represent
them and many of them are contesting his
win
[Music]
Nigeria's elections always seem to be
decided in the courts and opposition
parties have 21 days to appeal the
result given the president-elect won't
be inaugurated until May the months to
come will be critical to truly
understanding what the outcome of this
election really is
[Applause]
purple